so I'm curious in all of this it seems
like my relationship with all the kids
the adult kids is really off too
have you been talking to the adult kids
about this no we don't we rarely no one
wants to talk about this
I think your relationship is off with
your kids because of covet not because
of me
bull you're telling them
it's Christine telling them she's
running to this person to this person to
this person to this person to complain
about the relationship she's playing a
game she's been playing games for years
I just called
hey
I cannot figure out why I'm so angry
I mean it is sad I've seen you I've seen
you grieving Cody like in a way I've
never seen you grieve before
you disguise it but it's grief
I don't know how to explain it he's just
been off he's he's gone
to a more Angry Place quickly quicker
than he ever did I finally realized it's
a it's a grieving process for him
I guess maybe I'm mad because I feel
like an investor who poured everything
you know that he had into something and
and then
you know just didn't work in our
marriage I was putting so much effort I
was holding her hand I was kissing her
well I wasn't in love I was doing it it
was my duty as a husband
and and she's not either I mean she quit
loving me years ago and now that we're
here I'm just so upset because it's like
it's it's not the breakup of two people
it's the breakup of a family
[Music]
thank you